はい よろしくお願いします
日本テーラワーダ仏教協会があの
行っているこの仏教を紹介する講演
なんか私を頼ま...頼まれて
まあ判断ミスだなと思いますけど
まあとにかく講演を行いたいと思います
はい  primeroにスリランカでターナピティカーリャ
ターナーティトマーティガターナーティマーアペウソエタ
サンバンディミニサ サンバンディミガナ
アピ いたまくまアピゲストゥティエプドケロナ
アイワゲメスリランカウェーキーパデネク
メウソウェーバランドーナケレペミニャ
アイワゲナアペスワミンのハンセルアッタンラティヌ
セルデナートモ メデッサンアルサンバンディムピリバント
マゲストゥティ パロミン
プラカーサケロナ それは日本語であまりようなことにして
これから話を始めます
今日のテーマはね あの
もしあなたが悩んでいるならということで
あの 皆様の光をちょっと消しましたけど
まあ顔を見たら誰も悩んでいるような顔はしていなかったんですね
だから今日のテーマはなかなか合わないかもしれません
この間 ある出版社の方でちょっと音をちょっと下げた方がいいと思いますけど
すごい はい あの出版社のところでなんか私としゃべり話しまして
あの この協会のメンバーの方々はもうかなりスマートで痩せているんだと
だからこの 痩せるためには仏教はとてもいいんじゃないかと思いますよとまあ言われたんですね
何か秘密はあるのかと
私は初めてそんなことを聞かれて
秘密はあるかどうか分からなかったんですけど
後で思い浮かびました
私の話を聞いてみんな痩せているんで
食欲がなくなったりして
だから皆さんはもう痩せるかもしれません
この講演聞いていくと
お釈迦様の教えがあなたを今すぐ幸福にしてみせるということで
まず考えてみるポイントがいくつかございます
なぜあなたは車に電車に飛び込まないのですか？なぜ火遊びをしないのですか？なぜ包丁を丁寧に使うのですか？なぜ出かける時戸締りするのですかと
なぜ欠かすことなくご飯を食べるのですか？とか
なんででしょうかね おそらく考えたことないと思いますけどね
疑問を複数に作れますが
なぜに対する答えは何でしょうかね
ちょっと考えてほしいんです
なぜ車に電車に乗るととても気をつけるんですかと
飛び込まないんですね
車の前に 電車の前に で
そういうことには皆様いろいろ答えを出すと思います
なぜ電車に飛び込まないのかというと
死ぬからとかね なぜ包丁丁寧に使いますか？というと怪我するからとか答え出すでしょうね
私は一つの答えが欲しいんです
例えばお腹が空くからご飯食べるとかね
泥棒が入るから戸締りをするとか
まあ特別な答えを言うでしょう
などなどの答えを考えているでしょうが
すべての質問に一つの答えがあるんでしょうか
あります 危険であることはわかっているからなんです
今 前に出した質問 全部一言葉でまとめると危険なんですね
包丁も危険で 泥棒に入られることも危険なんですね
で 電車に飛び込んだら危険なんですね
だから危険であることは知っているんです
我々の問題はわかっているのでしょうか
納得しているのでしょうかということなんです
そこで私が言いたいことは
我々は納得しているならば
何かわかっているならば
そういうことをやらないんです
だから決して火遊びはしません
分かっているんです 納得しているんです
危険であることを しかし
宗教とかなんとかになってくると
うるさいほど説教があるんですね
嘘をつくなかれ 怠けるなかれ
真面目に勉強しなさい
真面目に働きなさい 詐欺
インチキ 不正 不正などをするなかれ
怒ってはならない 嫉妬してはならないなどなど
いくらでもあります まあうるさいんです
で 説教できない人はいませんね
世の中で 良いとされる生き方なら知らない人はいないようですね
では なぜ生きることは悩みだけに富んでいるのでしょうか
ということは問題なんですよ
正しい生き方はみんな知ってるんです
よく言われますね 小さい時からよく言われますが
なかなか人生は一向に幸福にはならないんです
豊かといえば悩みでは豊かなんですね
他のことでは豊かではないんです
それは何かあるみたいんですよ
秘密は あれはわかっているつもりだけかなと
嘘をついてはいけないと知っているのに
わかっているのに 嘘をつくなら
その人は知っていないのでわかってもいないのです
ここがポイントなんです
火は触るなよと言わなくても触らないんです
包丁を振り回して遊ぶなよと言わなくても
我々は遊ばないんです
電車が来るとちゃんと後ろ下がってホームに待っているんです
顔を出そうとしないんです
言わなくても大丈夫です
が 嘘をつくなよと言ったら
みんなそんな当たり前だよと
嘘をついたらとんでもないんだと
は言うんだけど 言う人も嘘をつくんですね
怠けてるは怠けてはいけませんよと言うんだけど
この言ってる人も堂々と怠けるんです
何なのかね これは と 答えは本当はわかってるつもりでわかってないんです
昔からこのように言われているという論理で生き方について語っているんです
私たちは何のことなく
オウム返ししているだけ
昔から嘘をつくなかれと言ってるんだからということでわかってないんですよ
納得してないんです 言ってる人も聞いてる人も
どのように生きれば幸福になるのか
どのような生き方が正しいのかわかっていないんです
ですから 仏教は特別な教えで
理解しなさい 理解しなさい
納得しなさいということをものすごく言うんです
理解したら楽だよと だから仏教は宗教かもしれませんだけど
もう宗教の特色は一つも持ってない
反宗教的な宗教なんですね
理解することは信仰に勝るんです
理不尽なことを 勝手なことを人に押し付けたければ
神の言葉 伝統 文化 聖書など何かを出せば結構です
例えば 聖書にこのように書かれているんだとかね
聖書たくさんありますからね
世の中で 各宗教には自分の聖書があるんですね
で 聖書にそう書かれているんだから
あなたやりなさいと言うと
この本人やりたくないんですよ
あれは理不尽なことなんです
あれ なんでまた？と聞きたくなるんです
そういう人が納得しない
やりたくないものを強引に押し付けたければ
まあ私には神様が耳元でこんなこと言い回ったとかね
もう何とか言うんですよ
あれは昔から伝統はそうなってるんだそうとかね
昔から伝統はそうなってるんだから
あんたやりなさいよと
本人がやりたくないと言ったっても
もうもうダメですね だから
この世の中で人々の考える自由
生きる自由 自分で判断する自由
すべてを奪って 奪って
強引にいろんなことをやらせるために
また理不尽なことをやらせるために
まあそういうものを使うんですよ
だからまとめて言えば信仰なんですね
それはとても良くないことだと思います
例えば天国では特等席が用意してありますよと言うと
若者が自分の腰回りに爆弾を付けて自爆して
ものすごい何人が殺すんですよ
で 自分も死ぬんです なぜならば
天国で特等席が用意してあるんだからと
だったら保証を出してくださいと言いたいんですけどね
特等席の番号とかね もう出してくれと
普通我々はね あなたにはもう野球試合のね
椅子を用意していますからと言ったっても
やっぱりチケットを手に入らない限りは信頼できないんですよ
ちゃんと偽物でない本物のチケット
座席番号もあって 手に入ったならば
はい わかりましたと は信頼できますが
しかし 人間はそこまで論理的じゃないんですね
信仰でやられちゃいますよ
だから信仰で嘘をつくなよと言ったっても
あまりうまくいかないんですよ
人を殺すなかれと言ったっても
信仰やらいろんなものを信じる人々はやっぱりやってしまうんです
証明する必要も 相手に納得させる必要も
相手に異論を立てる権利もなくなるんですね
こういう風な強引に物事を言うと
しかし 仏教はいつでも証明して喋るんです
相手に相手が納得するまで説明するんです
相手の異論を聞きます
異論があったら言ってくださいと
仏教の特色は 盲目的に信仰する召喚を理解
納得ということに変えることです
だから仏教はこの違うところと覚えておいてください
仏教は何か普通の宗教
大学の宗教学で学ぶ場合もちょっとややこしいんですね
もう世界宗教と対称にならないんですね
その枠に入らないんです
学者は困るのは結構構いませんだけど
仏教は全く別な特色を持っているんです
特にこの納得しなさい
理解しなさいというところはね
今日は経典引入できないので残念ですけど
経典にそうあるんです
それにお釈迦様が信と言うんですね
これパーリ語でアーカーラヴァティーサッダーと言うんですね
アーカーラティーサッダーっていうのは
もうラショナルフェイという風に英訳できますけどね
論理的に考えて あ なるほど
本当かもしれませんと
で 仏教でいう信は信仰ではないんですよ
確信というか 納得なんですね
ですから我々は理性を大切にしなくちゃいけないんです
信仰ではなく 理解することで幸福な生き方が始まるんです
だから皆様 全然もう悩んでいる顔もしていないんだから
悩みについて語ることはやめました
ですから その代わりに我々はよく物事を理解する人間になってみましょうと
物事を理解する人間になってみたら
かなり人生は幸福になるんです
ちょっとトラブルみたい
仏教は負け組のたまり場ではないと
これは今日のテーマについての自分の感想なんですけど
あの もしもあなたは悩んでいるならということになってくると
なんかちょっと悩んでる人寄ってこいような話ですけど
悩んで悩み果てているならば負け組ですからね
悩んでる人を助けるというと
悩んでない人は 助けがいりませんね
宗教に興味を持っただけで問題児とされる
変だと思われるんでしょうに
日本の状況はそういう状況なんですよ
なんか宗教っていうのは負け組が行くところで
御利益を 商売繁盛 何だらかんだらとかね
家庭の安全 安穏 繁栄とかね
そこをうまくいかない場合は
信仰にでも走って 裏口ででもなんとかやってもらおうかなという世界に
そういう常識になっているんですね
だから ものすごく残念なことに
宗教に興味持っちゃうと
負け組の人やということが
もう社会はそう思ってるんです
また 時々子供も別に負け組じゃないんだけど
なんか異様に宗教世界に
精神世界に興味持ったりするんですよ
子供はいろんなものに興味もしますよ
しかし 日本では怪獣とかね
おもちゃとかパソコンのコンピューターゲームとか
ゲームボーイに興味持ってならばすごい立派な常識な子供で
1 日中ゲームボーイでいじっているならば
勉強もやめてもうかっこいい男な子供なんですね
しかし その子はもう宗教って何なのかとかね
神様って何なのかどうか
死んだらどこか生まれるのかどうか
そういうことに興味持っちゃうと
うちの子はちょっと頭がおかしいと思ったりするんですよ
道徳に興味持っちゃうと
まあなんかうちの子はということになっちゃうんですね
ブッダの教えは 問題がある人の悩みを解決して社会に送り出すための雇われている組織ではありません
宗教はそういう社会の裏口の仕事していますよ
かっこ悪いんです  社会人をよくおとなしくしてあげて
真面目に偉い人の話を聞くロボットにしてあげて
社会に送り出すと それから宗教も世界宗教はね
権力者 政治家とかね の後ろにいて
この権力独裁者をね 応援してあげたりするんです
大量の人を殺したりすると
後ろに宗教が応援しているんです
ユダヤ人が殺したことの場合でも
第二次世界大戦で裏は宗教はそれ応援していたんですよ
そういうことで この宗教っていうのは
この社会の勝手口で 裏口で社会を助けてあげるとか
社会の不公平不正を助けてあげるような組織ですから
仏教も同じだと思ったらそれは勘違いです
仏教は社会で失敗する人を直してあげて
社会に送り出すと そういうことには興味ないんです
学校に行きたくないという人がね
登校拒否している人がなんとか頑張ってもう奮い立たせてあげて
もう学校に行くようにしてあげるとかね
私はそういうことを頼まれたらやりますよ
しかし 子供に言うんですよ
あのね 学校にあんた行きなさいよと
しかし 行ったってもろくなことはないんだよと
で 会社で会社に行きたくない
なんだらかんだら言う人にはね
まあとにかく会社に行きなさいよと
しかし 幸福になるとは勘違いしないでくださいと
あんたはもう使い捨てにして捨てられますよと
それで覚悟の上で行ってくださいということをちゃんと言います
だから人生は別だよということなんです
生命とは 生きるとは何かと仏教は具体的に論理的に語って解決策を提示するんです
はい これが答えなんです
仏教のテーマが生命って何ですか？生きてるっていうことは何ですか？なんで生きてるようであらゆる問題があるのか
何が答えがあるんでしょうかと
それ全部知り尽くして答えまで出してるんです
そういうわけで 具体的に考える必要がありますよ
生きるとはということは
ある特定の人のことではなく
一切の生命に対して生きるとは何かと
その真理を釈尊が語られたんです
一人一人で私の人生って何なのかとかね
こんな人生でいいのかとかね
そんな一人一人考えても何の意味もないんです
で 私が仕事を間違って選んだとかね
私は大学で間違った分野を研究することになっちゃったんだから
私の人生って一体何なのか
そんなこと困らなくていいんですよ
だって人生っていうのはリセットできませんし
医学部に入りたかったんですけど
入ったのは文学部だったら文学やればいいんです
別にどっちでやったってもろくな結果がないんだからね
医者になったっても まあもう悲しい人生で
毎日もうわがままの患者さんばっかし見ているんだからね
全く面白くないと思いますよ
もう可愛い人に会うことはできないんです
おばあちゃんおじいさんには毎日ですけどね
これまたわがままばっかしで
だからろくなことないんですよ
文学部にして 何かどこかの会社で社員になったってもね
同じことなんです だからまあそういうことに悩むのはバカバカらしいんです
間違っても構いませんよ
自分にはもう合わない仕事を選んでしまったと
まあこれから合わせればいいんですよ
そういうことは一体私の人生って何やと
結婚してみたら 相手がなかなか性格が合わないんだと
一体私の人生って何やとか
だからって回ぐらい離婚して再婚するんですかね
そんなのはややこしいんですからね
だからそういうことはまあ適当にまあ手を打っちゃえばいいんです
そんな大げさなことじゃないんです
そういうことに足が引っ張られると
我々は偉大なる問題にかかる時間がなくなるんです
だから お釈迦様がある特定に私の人生って何なのかと悩むんじゃなくて
生命に対して生きることは何かということを語ってくれたんです
このその真理を理解して納得してもらうと
その人は智慧のある人
人間になります 生命って何ですか？とものすごく幅広く理解すると
この世の中でものすごいトップクラスの智慧なんです
生命って何なのか 生きるということの何なのかで
それだけ知っておけば
皆様方はその日から人類の中でリーダーで生きられます
どんな問題も解決できない
できます すごい智慧なんですよ
それは簡単に身につけます
だから 今日のテーマの目的は
まあちょこちょこっとした悩みを解決ではなくて
絶対的生きる問題の悩みをね
解決することなんです
で 苦しみを克服します
最大の幸福に達します
ということで なんか行き過ぎ
そういうことで 生きるとは何やと勉強してみましょう
興味ないとは言ってはいけません
私は会社で仲間とちょっとトラブってますけど
それだけ解決すれば十分だよと思ったらね
これあまり安すぎですよ
軽く見すぎなんです そんな程度ではなくて
もっと最大のスケールで
人生って何なのか 生きるということは何なのかと
そこを理解しておけば
何のことなく小さな小さな問題は
あの あのビニールのシートありますね
物を包装する 包装するとき使う
あの 何といいますか 空気入れちゃって
あのなんかポチポチポチポチと潰しちゃえば
あのポチポチシート 名前わかりません
あれ ポチポチシートあったらいくらでもポチポチポチと潰れるでしょうに
何のことなく 人生で起こる問題っていうのは
私がポチポチシートで空気入ってる玉を潰すような感じで潰してほしいんです
どうってことないんです
例えば会社で同僚はね
自分のことをあまりよく思わない場合はね
あ こんにちはと先に挨拶すればね
先輩と一緒に仕事ができて
本当に私はついてるんだよと
遅いでも一回二回言ってみてください
それで終わりですよ 話は
その大げさなことじゃないんです
奥さんが機嫌が悪くて
毎日いろんなことを言っていて
いじめてるんだったらね
それでも君と結婚してよかったねとかね
よく私のことまで心配していて
一回だけ言ってみてください
それ全部終わりますよ
だから人生の問題っていうのは
ポチポチシートのポチを潰すぐらい簡単ですよ
それが大げさに取っちゃうとどうするんですかね
だからもっと大きく生きるとは何やということは
問題解決すると その人は超越した智慧の人になるし
生きる苦しみを克服するし
最大の究極的な幸福に達するんです
それが仏教の仕事なんです
はい では 生きるとは何なのかということで
今日は難しいところはできるだけ排除して
わかりやすいところをいくつかだけ紹介いたします
時計はないので ちょっと
話の中身は時計によります
あ もう スピードを上げなくちゃいけないみたい
今から紹介するポイントを理解してください
すぐたちまち人生はもう幸福になってしまいます
1番目はアニッチャーということで
一切はすべての現象は無常ですというポイント
パーリ語でサッベーサンカーアニッチャーと言うんですね
悩みをなくすのではなく
増やしてくれるくらい話だと思ってるでしょうね
そんなことはすべては無常やと
なんて暗い話ですかと
残念ながらこれは事実です
暗い話じゃないんです
絶対的神だと自画自賛している者にも
この真理は間違っているとは言えないんです
これ 私は神を侮辱しているんじゃないんです
お釈迦様そうおっしゃっているんだから
私に何も言わないでください
誰が来たってもね この真理は違いますよと言えませんよと
というのはお釈迦様の自慢なんです
だから私も遠慮なく言います
ますので いろいろ宗教ある方々はちょっと勘弁してください
かなり言います で 無常であることは事実なんです
はい 解説に行きます 無常だから変わるのだから生きているということが成り立つんですよ
皆様は知らないでしょうね
我々は最初にこの世で 1個の細胞で生まれたんですよ
見えなかったんです 目にも
たった 1個の細胞 これが無常だからすぐ壊れちゃったんです
すぐ壊れて  2つに  4つに
8つになったり  １６ ３２
になったり こうやって細胞が弾けて弾けて新しいものが生まれるんですよ
新しいものが生まれると
母親のおなかの中にいたんだから
母親の物質を取って取って
新しい細胞を作るんですよ
だから無常でなければどうやって成長するんですかね
生まれた赤ちゃんがみるみるうちに変化していくでしょうね
だから生きているというんですよ
だから無常だから命が成り立っているんです
無常でないなら 勉強してもご飯を食べても何の意味もないんです
大変なことになりますよ
お腹が空いて死にそうになっていて
ご飯食べる でも全ては無常ではありません
だから幸福感はそのまんまなんです
どうなるんですかね 無常だから
ご飯一口食べたら幸福感が消えちゃうんです
それで苦しみがなくなって楽しいんです
それから満腹感 苦しいでしょう
それでご飯食べても食べても無常でないならば感じませんよ
大変なことになるんです
だから無常がありがたくて
無常のおかげで生きているんです
世界が存在が成り立たないんです
無常でないと 皆様方 音楽を楽しんでいるでしょう
無常でないと音楽は成り立たないんです
私はよく言う例がありまして
ピアノが好きな人がいる
バイオリンが好きな人がいる
楽器の場合は 例えばピアノの演奏が大好きな人がいるとすると
ピアノのノート一つだけ 1分
2分ぐらい落として 何て言いますか
叩いてみたらどうですかね
1個だけ 例えばドだったらドだけ
レだったらレだけ ポンポンポンポンポンポンって叩く
吐き気がしますよ このバイオリンはもっとひどいんです
バイオリンの弦を一つのノートだけガーッと弾くと
もう聞いていられませんよ
鳥肌が立つんです 気持ち悪くて
しかし 指が激しく動いて
ものすごく激しく指が動いて
バイオリンの上でも ピアノのキーボードの上でも動くと美しい音楽なんですよ
じっと聴いていられますよ
無常でなきゃ音楽は成り立たないんです
何でもそうなんですよ
皆様の脳細胞 頭が無茶無情なんですよ
だから勉強できるんですよ
いくら勉強しても 自分の知識だけは永久的に変わらないんだと思ったら
バカで終わっちゃうでしょ
人生は だから無常で存在が成り立っているんです
楽しみも苦しみも無常だから現れては消えていく
しかし 我々は事実に背くんですよ
無常はそんな暗い話嫌だとかね
だから仏教は葬式には呼ばれますけど
結婚式には呼ばれませんでしょ
暗い話するんだから 冗談じゃないと思いますけどね
本当はこちらも結婚式には行きたくないだけなんです
だって みるみるうちに不幸は不幸に陥ることを知っていて
どうやってそれを応援でき
祝福できますかね 行きたくないんです
呼ばないでください で
しかし 仏教こそがすごい幸福な話をしているんですよ
で 人間が事実に背くんですよ
おかしいんです だから一部の無常を認めて楽しんでいるが
一部の無常を見たく認めたくないので
必死で逆らおうと無駄に努力するんです
一部だけ無常は欲しいんです
だけ一部はいらないんですね
地球の自転公転と同じく無常という事実は
誰の希望にも配慮はしないんです
無常は無常法則です 自分の好みで無常になったり
無常でなくなったりはできません
例えば 赤ちゃんがすくすくと成長しますよ
そのスピードは死ぬまで変わらないんです
それで二十歳まで成長してほしいと
二十歳から止めてくれと
これはちょっと無理です
ありえないんです 二十歳になっても体は変化するんです
じゃあ二十歳で まあ今三十五歳で止めてほしいと思ってるでしょ
みんな それはないんです
だから一部の無常がありがたくて
一部の無常がありがたくないというのはいい加減
真理ではありません 例えば
夏の暖かさが欲しい人が
今暖かくて気持ちいいんだと
だから地球の自転は止まってくれと
そんなことはできませんよ
冬も来ますからね 冬は好きな人は地球の自転自転止まってくると思ったら
それはできませんね だから無常に慣れちゃえば楽なんですよ
無常を認めれば楽なんですよ
赤ちゃん の成長は楽しいんだけど
そのうちいやらしい人間になるんだそうと最初から覚えておけば
結婚するとすごい美人と結婚できて
私は幸せでしたと でもまあ一年でしょうと
ということで 全て物事は変わるんだということで生活すれば楽なんです
無常を無視するなら 無視するから
期待 希望 願望などが生まれ
欲 怒り 無知の感情で不幸に陥るんですよ
だから無常は無視するでしょ
だから永遠に若くていたいとかね
絶対病気にはなりたくないんだとかね
痴呆症には私はなりたくないんだとかね
私は寝たきりになりたくない
あれやこれやと思ったりするんですよ
大金持ちになりたいとかね
希望ばっかり作るんですけど
そう希望を作っただけではうまくいかないんです
そうすると怒りが出るんですね
年取ると怒るんですよ
体が弱くなると なんで私に限って弱くなったんでしょうかとかね
病気になるとガンだと言われると
なんで私に限ってとかね
ものすごく怒ったりして落ち込んだりはしますよ
だから怒りが現れるのは
欲が現れるのは初めから無知でしょうしね
それで不幸になるんです
無常で不幸になりません
えーと 無常を智慧で認める人に
何が起きても悩みはありません
無常やと分かった人は悩みません
ああ そうか それで終わるんです
ちょっと調子が悪くて
お医者さんに頼んだところで
もう何回も調べたんですけど
ちょっとがんみたいですよと
悪性だよと ああ そうか
それで終わっちゃいます
無常な人は だって別に不思議なものが起こったわけじゃないんだからね
ああ そうですか なるほど
それですごく冷静にいられますよ
無常に逆らう無知な人が
なんで先生 それ間違いじゃないんですか？もう一度調べてくださいと
もうセカンドオピニオン
サードサードオピニオンとかね
できれば百五十三番目のオピニオンも聞きたくなるんですね
ガンでないと言って欲しくて
そういうことになりますよ
だから無常だったら まあファーストオピニオンでまあいいわ
別にという感じになるんです
だから無常っていうのは
人の幸福は潰せないんです
しかし 無常を認めるために智者でなければいけません
無常という真理は簡単に納得いくものではありません
死ぬことは当然だと知っているが
なんとかなりませんか？心の中で思っているんでしょう
無常を知る智者は 今の瞬間
今の状況はそのままで永遠だとは思わないんです
まあ例えば会社は倒産するは
病気になるは色々ありますけど
心の中でそうはなって欲しくないとわかってはいるんだけど
なって欲しくないんだと
人は誰でも死ぬんだけど
しかし俺だけは死にませんし
死にたくはないというふうに愚者が無常に逆らうんですよ
心の中で 私は無常の話をすると
よく日本で言われた言葉がありまして
日本人なら無常はよくわかっているんだよと
だってなんとか物語でもね
なんか無常の歌ってなんとか何だら歌もありますから
それまで教えてくれたんですけど
わざと忘れたんです あの祇園精舎のなんだらかんだらですけどね
で 嫌でわかってないんです
無常は調子に乗ってはいけませんと思ったんです
だからそういうものではなくて
感情で歌うものじゃなくて
無常っていうのは科学的な事実ですよ
感情はいりません ちょっと理解してもらえば
だから私たちはまあ無常であって欲しくないという余計な希望がありますから
問題なんですよ 次の瞬間に構えるから
常に活発で明るいのです
無常の人が 今は今の瞬間で
次は別変わりますからということでそちらに構えているんですよ
だから無常が無常に納得した人がいつまでも明るくなるんです
もう活発で落ち込む暇がないんです
なんでこうなったのかと落ち込まないんです
こうなるのは当たり前で
次にどうしましょうかと
次のことに挑戦するんです
例えば人が病気で倒れたら
あ なるほど 病気で倒れたか
じゃあ次にどうしましょうかと
次のことを考えるんです
明るいんです 無常を知らないと
ああ なんだこれ 大変だ
どうしよう どうしようと途方に暮れてしまいますよ
だから心臓発作でも起こったらもう手遅れになるんですよ
無常が知っている人 ああ
そうか すぐさっさと行動しなくちゃということで
ものすごい元気になるんです
無常を知っておけば はい 2
番目の真理 一切の生命に対して生きることは苦であるということが2番目の真理なんです
これパーリ語でサッベーサンカーラドゥッカ
これもまた悩みをなくすのではなく
増やしてくれる暗い話だと思われるでしょう
残念ながら これはまた事実です
生命は苦という衝動で生きているんです
解説難しいながらすぐ飛ばしちゃったんです
生きることは動くことです
これからゆっくり解説します
生きるということは本当に可哀想でシンプルなんです
時々宗教ではね もう仏様は如来様が与えてくれた尊い命を持っているんだぞとか思っているでしょうに
あれは嘘です 神様がね
永遠不滅の尊い命を 霊魂を入れてくれたと思って調子に乗ってるでしょ
嘘です あれも そんなの科学的な証明は何もないんです
ただ 人はバカだと知ってるんだから
カモにされてるだけ 搾取するために
おだてるために 乗りたい人は同窓自由に乗ってください
その話に 科学的に見るとそんなの何にもないんです
永遠な魂があるんだったら
なんで見つからないんですかね
いくら調べたっても 瞬間瞬間変わるものしか見つかるくはないんです
それで生きるといえば動くことですよ
細胞一個顕微鏡で見ても
この細胞が生きているか否かということはよくわかるんです
どうやってわかりますか？生きている細胞はグニャグニャ動いているんです
この動きを少々でも止めてみると耐えがたい苦痛になるんです
面白いんですよ この動きを止めてみると
恐ろしく苦しくなるんです
じゃあ例を出します 試しに二
三分息を止めてみてください
生まれてからずっと呼吸しているでしょ
では試してみてください
息を吐き出して止めてみる
三分ぐらい 我慢できませんよ
あまりも苦しくて私を殴られるかもしれません
なんでこんなことさせるのかと
それぐらい苦しいんですよ
それでもやり続けると死んでしまいますよ
だから生き物っていうのは動くんです
動きが止まると ものすごい耐えがたい苦しみがあるんです
これが科学的な事実なんです
あの筋肉を痙攣したり
いきなりすごく痛くなったりしますね
私はしょっちゅうですけど
足の筋肉とかね ものすごい痛くて
もうもうたまらないんですよ
その時私はこのふくらはぎを触ってみるんですよ
硬くなっているんです
痛くてたまらない 硬くなったら
それでなんとかなんとかして
またほぐしてあげれば
また痛みがなくなるんです
皆様も肩が凝ってる凝ってると言ってるでしょうね
硬いでしょう 動きが鈍いんですよ
動きが鈍くだっただけでも苦しいんです
もうたまたま心臓でも動かないで
ちょっとまあ二 三分ぐらい止めたらどうなるんですかね
人は漏らすんですよ その時は
心臓が止めたらそれぐらい苦痛なんです
だから苦で生きているんです
だから我々は絶えず動かなくちゃいけないんですよ
動きが止まったら生命は死んでるんです
息を吸って止めても苦ですが
吐いて止めても苦なんです
ですから 絶えず呼吸しなくてはならないんです
生きることは 瞬間に感じる苦しみから逃げる動きなんです
それはブッダの話ですよ
しかし 科学者にもそれ違いますよと言えませんよ
生きるということは 今の瞬間の苦しみから次の瞬間に引っ越しするんです
皆様方もなんで丁寧に座ってないんですかね
ぐにゃぐにゃ ぐにゃぐにゃ
ぐにゃぐにゃ なんだこれ
それって何ですか？わかりますかね
なんか置物のように座ってると痛いんですよ
気持ち悪くなるんです
だから こんな立派な椅子に座っていても
椅子でもぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃぐにゃしているんです
そうでないと痛くてたまらないんですよ
今 長い時間座って話を聞いてたでしょ
もう飽き飽きしているでしょうに
もう早く終わってくれという気分でしょうに
それが人生なんです 何やってもこうなんです
苦から苦へ逃げるのでも
また逃げなくてはならないんです
生きるということは 一つの苦しみから別な苦しみに逃げるんです
それで落ち着かないんですよ
納得いかないんですね
人生は 不満 虚しさを感じるんです
だってやってもやってもやってもやっても
またやらなくちゃいかんでしょ
朝ごはん作って食べるわ
また昼ごはんも作って食べなくちゃいかんでしょうに
それで終わればいいのに
また夜になってくるとまたお腹が空くでしょうに
これどこまでやるんですかね
結局死ぬまでやらなくちゃいけないでしょうに
この家の奥様方はね これで結構苦労してるでしょうに
毎日毎日毎日献立考えなくちゃいけないんですね
同じもの作っちゃえばいいでしょ
はっきり決まって 昼これ
夜これと 絶対変わりません
死ぬまではと やっぱりそれでダメなんですよ
変わらなきゃ苦しいんです
例えば 朝も食パン食べて
昼も食パン食べて 夜も食パン食べることになっちゃうと
もう食欲がないんです
気持ち悪いんです というわけで
苦しみがあって我々は生きているんです
しかし こんなことどこまでやるのかという
キリがないんじゃないかということもあるんですよ
だから どんな人でも人生には納得していないんですよ
不満を持ってるんです
落ち着かないんです これは生きること苦だからなんです
怒るんです 希望をそぐんです
こうなってほしい ああなってほしいとかね
勘違いの幸福 お腹が空くと苦しいんです
ご飯を食べると楽しみを感じる
しかし 食べるとまた苦しみが起こるので
食べることをやめるんです
空腹苦を満腹苦で置き換えたんです
覚えてください これは辞書にない言葉なんですけどね
空腹苦を満足苦に置き換えるんです
結局答え答えは同じですけどね
空腹も苦ですけど 満腹も苦なんです
しかし 苦から苦へ引っ越しするとき
苦苦がなくなるので楽を感じるんです
しかし 辛苦が起こるんです
この単語も覚えておいてください
苦苦と辛苦 辞書にはないんです
仏教の言葉はやっぱり辞書に載ってないんです
そういうことになるんです
お腹が空いて苦しいんでしょ
ご飯食べると空腹という苦しみが逃げて逃げるんですよ
その時だけ楽しいんですよ
しかし その代わりに満足という苦しみが溜まっていくんです
あの引っ越しする間だけ楽しいんですよ
楽しいと感じるんです
苦苦が消えていっただけで
新たに幸福が生まれたのではありません
これ よく覚えた方がいいと思いますよ
人生には楽が生まれませんよ
ただ苦しみが消えるだけで
新たな苦が割り込むんですね
英語で言えばリプレースするんですね
置き換える 古い苦を新しい苦で置き換える
例えば 独身で苦しいなら
結婚という新しい苦しみでそれを置き換えるんです
そこで独身でいた苦しみが消えますよ
その時なんて幸せだとは思います
しかし 結婚生活という新しい苦しみがもう生まれているんです
それで人間は辛きろうんですね
生きることには大変な幸福があるのだと思って
皆それを探しているんです
ないんですけどね 知識を得たり
財産を作ったり よく頑張ってます
結婚したり 家族を作ったり
独身でいたり 家を作ったり
権力を握ったりするでしょ
幸福になろうと思って
誰もなりませんよ どんなことをやっても
ただ苦が消えるだけ 苦が消えて新しい苦が生まれるだけなんです
しかし 見つかりませんね
明るい未来を目指して頑張るが
今の状況では 今の生き方では満足しないのです
よく日本で聞こえる単語なんですよ
明るい 明るい未来を目指して頑張ろうではないかと
子供たちによく言うでしょ
君たちの明るい将来が待ってるんだよと
私はそういうこと言わないんです
そうすると あの子供たち侮辱したことになるんです
だって今はあんた方クタクタ疲れてもう不幸でいるんだよと
今楽しく生きてみましょうと
なんで人を言わないんですかね
学校は楽しみましょう
勉強そのものを楽しみましょう
明日はどうでもいいやと
数学を楽しみましょうと
数学を学んだら人生の役に立つと思うと
そんな恐ろしいことを思うなよと
役に立ちませんよと 地理学を楽しく学びましょうと
地理学者になったんだから何かなるのか
何にもなりません そういうことで
今楽しめばいいのに みんな明るい将来目指してますね
この明るい将来を語る人々こそが悲観主義者で
極限に不幸を語っているんです
智者は苦を教えるんです
たまたま苦があっても
生きることは何よりも価値のあるかけがえのないものだと
一般人は苦を認めないが
智者は現れるのも苦 生まれるのも苦
変化して続くのも苦 やがてなくなるものも苦であって
苦以外何もないんだよと知っているんです
命とは一切苦で現れて
苦で構成されて 苦で維持管理されて
苦で死にますよと 智者はそれを知ってますよ
ですから 少々のことで
期待はずれのことで動揺しない
冷静にいるんです ちょっと足が痛くなっただけで
お腹が壊しただけで 智者は何もないんです
子供が病気になっただけで
会社がクビになっただけで
もう動揺しない それぐらいに動揺して
なんか世紀末来たような感じでね
何するんですかね 別に
何でももう苦だよと 会社がクビになっても苦しいし
クビにならないで毎日通勤する羽目になったっても苦しいんだからね
そんなに変わりがないんですよ
子供が遊ぼう遊ぼうと自分を責める時は疲れているくせにね
もう子供と一緒に遊ぶのも苦しいんですよ
もうもう体力がないんだからね
しかし 子供がもう親を置いておいて
無視して一人で遊んでると
また自分が寂しくて またそれも苦しいんですよ
どちらでも同じことだからね
冷静でいればいいんです
そういうわけで どちらでも同じ苦だよと知っている人はすごく冷静にいられます
ちょっとしたことではめげないんです
地震が起きたんだとか
家が潰れたんだとか あんまり気にしない
生きることに必死になって執着しない
これは 読み違いをするかもしれません
生きることには必死にならないんです
執着しない 気楽に生きているんです
生きるためなら何でもやるぞ
どんな罪でも犯すぞとは思わないんです
生きることは苦だから忍耐があるんです
苦に耐えられる 落ち着めているんです
苦を減らす方法を考えるんです
生きることはどうせ苦だから
何とか減らしてみましょうと
基本的な生きる苦をよりさらに余計な自分の希望で感情で加える苦を味わうことはしないんです
生きることは基本的に苦なんです
それは変わらないんです
コンスタントファクターなんですよ
いわゆる変わらないファクターなんです
我々はその上新しい苦しみを作るんですよ
例えば 階段でこけちゃったら痛いんですよ
それはもう誰にも同じなんですよ
それでなんでこけたんですか？とかね
なんでこんな階段はこちら高いんですか？とか
なんでこちら照明をつけてないんですか？とかね
今日は占ってみたら本当に悪い時あったんだからね
やっぱり当たったんです
そうやって新しい苦しみ作るんですよ
愚者は 智者はこけた 痛かった
それで終わっちゃうんです
最小限の苦を苦で生きるんです
普通の人間はこの最小限の苦を最大に増やすんです
それで最後と思いますけど
この必要な心理ヴィパッサナーという 3番目
一切の現象は因縁によって現れるということ
因縁がなくなると消えるんです
パティチサウパンナサンカーラの説明で
カエダンマワヤダンマニロダダンマ
今までサッベサンカーラドッカサッベサンカーラニッチャーと言ったんだから
今度はサンカーラの定義なんです
現象は因縁によって現れる
偶然 突然 奇跡 創造 神の意志などは成り立たない
これを断言できます そんなのはもう嘘です
原因で現れるんです これも真理
事実ですが 一般の人は理解しようとはしないんです
これもちょっと難しいんだからね
一応 今度はこの因果法則を説明します
何か期待できなかったこと
ありえないことが起こるから困っても結構です
わからないんですね 朝起きてみると
これ例えばなし 自分の子供がカラスになって窓から飛んで行ってしまったらね
確かに困るでしょ その時は大いに悩んでください
そういう突然 予測もできないことが起きたならば悩んでください
しかし この世でそういうものは起こりません
この世で起こることは一切原因があって
当然で当たり前で起こるんですよ
よくも当たり前のことに人は悩むんですよ
なんかバカバカらしくて
もうもうもう笑っちゃいますよ
子供がね 高熱出して本当に悩んでるんだよと
私は笑っちゃいます だからと子供がカラスになって飛んでいったら悩んでもいいんだけど
熱出すってことは当たり前のことでしょうに
気が動転するものは起こりませんよ
世の中 それが因果法則のすごいところなんです
因果法則が知らない人が自分が特定に神に恨み
恨まれているんだと 時々こういうことの場合あるんですよ
自分の家庭で体のちょっと不自由な子供が生まれてきてますね
障害何か持ったりして
そうすると親がやっぱり困るんですよ
親にとっては 自分の子供がものすごい健康で
元気でいてほしいんですよ
それは当たり前の希望で
はいいんだけど 生まれてきた子供を調べてみると
いろいろ障害を持っていると
そうするとお母さんがすごく悩むんですよ
そうすると宗教が助けてあげるんです
あのね お母さん 悩まなくてもいいんですよと
それは神様が何かわけがあって
そういう子供を作ったんだからと
そうすると そのアホな母親も
あ 神様の気持ちですからと言って頑張るんですね
これって失礼でしょうに
そういうふうに思っちゃうと
私がはっきり言った だったら頑張るなよと
子供が白血球に白血病になったのは神様の意思であるならば
病院に連れていくなよと
だって神様に逆らうことになるんだからね
私が言いたいのは 白血病だと治療は不可能やと言っても頑張りなさいよと
とにかく治療方法ないのかと探しなさいよと
見つかったら見つかったでありがたいし
見つからなかったらまあしょうがないと
で 因果法則を知っている人は変えようと頑張るんですよ
誰にも文句言いません
あり得るものは起こってるんです
しかし 人は当たり前を否定するんです
人が死にかかっていると
祈りでもして生かせてもらいたくなるんです
神に背任してもらってでも
我が子は試験に合格して欲しくなるんです
人生に起こる出来事は
夏は暑いのような当たり前のこととして冷静に見られるためには
仏説すたる因縁を認めざるを得ないんです
夏が暑いんだから困る
まあ困りますけど そんなにびっくりすることじゃないでしょ
当たり前だからね それなりの対応を取ればいいんです
夏は暑い 冬は寒いのように
世の中起こることはすべて自然で当たり前で当然なものなんです
気が動転するものは起こりません
だからそれ理解しましょう
理解すると気楽ですよ
頭が動くんです 因縁を知ると計画ができるんです
因縁によって現れるものは
その原因がなくなると消えるんです
例えば夏は暑いでしょうに
しかし この部屋は涼しいんですね
原因消してるんです 湿気を減らして温度を下げているんです
機械で だから気分がいいんです
そういうことは 原因が消えたら結果も変わるということなんです
何か期待する結果があるならば
どのように因縁を揃えば良いのかということは計画です
例えば 大学を合格したいという結果があるんです
それ結果です だったら
えーとなんでしたっけ？お札買うなよと私が言いたいんです
絵馬 絵馬というかなんとかの板に板切れでね
合格しますようにと書く
書いておくなよと  そういう神社やらお寺やらね
まあ続いてほしいんだから
お布施だけしてください
しかし 絵馬だけ書くなよと
書いたら家に持ってきて飾っておけば
で まあどうでもいいんですけど
大学合格したいという結果があるんだったら
原因があるんですよ 原因そろってください
必ず合格する 簡単で勉強すればいいんだからね
自分が通っている塾の先生は機嫌が悪いとかね
私の講演と同じく 何言ってるか
さっぱりわからないならば塾変えればいいんです
楽です しかし 私の話を変えますよと言ったら
テーラワーダ仏教聞けなくなりますけどね
もうまだまだ今若いお坊さんたちはこれから勉強して喋るでしょうと思いますけど
まあ期待してください
その前に死んじゃったら困りますからね
今日お話聞いた方がいいんです
大学合格したければ合格できますよ
100%確率で それには因果法則を知る必要があるんです
我々の計画は具体的な計画より希望のイラストに過ぎないんですよ
みんな因果法則を知らないんです
だから会社では 学校では
家ではいろんな計画を立てますでしょ
あれは計画じゃないんです
ただのイラストなんです
希望のイラスト 希望のイラストはいくらでも描けますよ
人間 ろくに計画立てることを知らないんです
だから困っているんです
計画はあるんだけど うまくいかないんだぞとかね
それは現実できないんですよ
イラストは 因果を知る人の計画は実現できるんです
無知な人は結果に悩むんです
我々の悩みというものは
すべて結果に悩むことです
病気になって悩んでいるんだと
子供が不良に走って悩んでいるんだと
旦那さんが不倫して悩んでるんだという悩みでしょ
学校でいじめられて悩んでるんだと
すべて結果なんですね
結果に悩むのはバカなんです
結果はどうしようもないんです
結果は確実に起こるんです
変えることはできません
今日たとえ出します これ読んでください
ビルの屋上から飛び降りる人がね
死んでやるそうと 突然気が変わるんですね
飛び降りてから ビルは 10階ぐらいの建物だとしてください
死んでやるそうと  10階の屋上から飛び降りたんですけど
両足が上がった瞬間にやっぱり
もう終わりでしょ もうやっぱりじゃないんです
結果はもう変わりませんよ
やっぱり誰かが もう何て言いますか
空気マットでも入れてほしいとかね
誰もいないんだから そちらは
だから結果に悩む必要はないんです
結果は結果で変わらないんです
原因で考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
時々人がいますよ 脅しして何とかしてくれなんか飛び降りて死ぬそうと言って看板を掲げて待ってるんです
屋上に その人 本当は飛び降りたくないんです
自殺はしたくないんです
何か訴えているんですね
その場合は 消防車の消防士の方々はもうなんかマットを敷いて空気を入れて待ってるんです
どうぞ飛び降りてくださいということで
そういうことだから 飛び降りたらもう終わりなんですよ
例えば 窓の窓ガラスを目掛けて石を投げると
自分の手から石が離れた瞬間でもう話が終わり
ガラスは割れます 後で気が変わったって意味がないんですよ
だから人間 この結果に悩んでるんだから
悩みは終わらないんですよ
因果法則で考えましょう
原因はいくらでも変えられますよ
原因を変えれば結果変わります
結果に悩むのは愚か者です
因縁知ってる智者は 原因の過程を先に調整するんです
学校でいじめられるならば
いろいろ別な工夫してみるんですよ
それで これで最後と思いますよ
生きるために必要な心理
メッタ  4番目 自我でエゴでわがままで生活するときは
結果は決まっているんです
不幸になる 失敗する 嫌われる
誰も心配しない 助けてくれない
自分一人で世界に対して対立しなくてはいけないんです
わがままな人は 自分は意図的に世界を敵に回しているんです
余計な敵を持たなくてはならないので
他人まで不幸になるんです
私がわがままだったら
私だけじゃなくて周りも不幸になるんですよ
だって周りの人と私を嫌
嫌にならなくちゃいけないでしょ
嫌なやつやとか思わなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だからわがままで生きると
自分が不幸に陥るのは勝手にいいんだけど
周りまで不幸になるんです
一切の生命に対して幸福でありますようにという気持ちで生活すると
自分が幸福になる権利を獲得している
周りはその人の幸福を期待する
応援する 一切の罪から心が離れる
一切の心配 悩むこと 困ることなどはなくなってしまう
行き過ぎ はい それで最後に我々は生きる権利を獲得しなくちゃいけないんです
幸福の権利 幸福の権利獲得したら
もう誰にも奪うことができないんです
どうやって獲得しますか？わがまま捨てます
すべての生命が幸福で生きていきたいんだから
私はその期待を持ちますよと
生きとし生けるものが幸福でありますようにと
その気持ちさえ心にあれば
確実に幸福になります
もう悩むことなくなっちゃうんです
みんな応援してくれます
みんな心配してくれます
助けてくれます で それから罪は犯せなくなります
嘘をつけなくなっちゃうんですよ
生命のことを心配する人
慈しむ人は嘘を言わない
暴力振るいません 生命を殺さないんです
だから自動的に善行為する人間になって
確実に幸福になります
はい それで幸福の道は真理を理解
理解すること 仏教は信仰じゃなくて理解でいくんです
信仰ではなく 理性でのみ悩みがなくなるんです
だから皆様には悩みがなくても
今日から理性の人間になるということに頑張ってください
終わりです どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]